[Music]
hello hi so you looking at me from the
street I'm assuming you're not with
anyone never see you with
anyone this see moment
daad
yeah they died
just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about him at the
moment how's it
going
strangely
hi
hi is this
real does it feel
real oh boys back home a
son look at you you were just a boy and
now you're
not it was a long time ago yeah I don't
think that
[Music]
matters I've always felt like a stranger
in my own
family always scared or
something always running away do you
[Music]
remember sorry I never came your room
when you were
crying it's funny doesn't take
much to make you feel the way you felt
back there
[Music]
again you think you like to be in love
with
[Music]
him I'd always felt
love this is a new feeling
you and
me
together into the
[Music]
world